WALKS
YOU HAVE ONE MAN WITH HAYDEN IN
FRONT.
WATCH WHEN HE COMES OUT.LATE.
HE IS STILL DOWN LOW IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE.
THOMPSPSNN WITH THE
EVENTUAL CHCHN.
SCORE!
THE GLOVE OF HOLTBY.
PERFECTLY
GUR FIANOV
PERIOD.
DRIVE DOWN THE LEFT THROUGH.
STARS LOOK FOR A QUICK TON OF FE
POWER.
WASN'T ABLE TO
CLEARNET.
A GOOD STICK KNOCKS IT AWAY HE
GOING.
HE
KLINGBERG. UP HIGH. HE'S TAKING
AGAINST THE BOARDS.
RAFFL FROM THE CORONNER.
OFF THE BACK OF DAHLIN.
ALEX TUCH WILL CARRY IT OVER THE
LINE.
SCORES!
PUCK WIDE.
HE LETS IT RIP RIGHT THERE.
HE BEATS H H FOR 2 SO FAR IN TH.
I JUST GOT OUT OF THE WAY
HE'S MET THERE BY EAKIN.
PLAYED BACK AT THE NEAR
POINT.
TAKES A RETURN PASS.
SENDS IT ACROSS.THERE.
YOU SEE TUCH AND THOMP STICK OF
ROBERTSON.
A GREAT CHANCE FOR HINTZTHERE.
ROBERTSON ABLE TO PICK IT RIGHT
OUT OF THE AIR AND TAP IT INTO
THE NET PAST